bienvenido a la meditación en
procrastinación
irónicamente estuve procrastinar la
realización de este vídeo así que
estamos juntos en el mismo barco como en
toda meditación la postura y la
respiración marcan la diferencia por eso
te recomiendo que encuentres un asiento
cómodo y firme si las piernas no se te
duermen también podría sentarse en el
piso pero intenta sentarte con la
espalda recta en una buena postura
inhala
y exhala
un poco más lento y más profundo
cada vez
puedes descansar las manos en tus muslos
a mí me gusta dejar las palmas hacia
arriba
y a tu tiempo puedes descansar la mirada
lentamente
y cerrar los ojos
inhala
exhala
la procrastinación es algo interesante
no estoy seguro de que los seres humanos
seamos los únicos animales conocidos que
procrastinar valdrá la pena que alguien
investigara eso pero definitivamente
nosotros lo hacemos
buena parte de la meditación se trata de
percatarnos de nuestros pensamientos
de observar nuestros pensamientos y de
darnos cuenta de que no somos nuestros
pensamientos
aunque a menudo parezca que nos
controlan o incluso nos abruman hagamos
lo intentemos observar esos pensamientos
que hacen que propongamos algo que
sabemos que debemos hacer
porque crees que estás posponiendo eso
te diremos lo que generalmente me sucede
a mí
normalmente me da temor empezar porque
puede resultar a ser más difícil de lo
que suponía
o porque puedo no hacerlo tan bien como
esperaría o puedo cometer un error o
pienso que quizá no estoy lo
suficientemente preparado para comenzar
otra forma de verlo es que nos
concentramos demasiado en el resultado
en lugar de disfrutar el proceso o de
disfrutar lo que sea que estemos
posponiendo
porque es solo una parte de esta
divertida experiencia y he encontrado
que cuando me digo a mí mismo
defínete por la acción y no por el
resultado no te definas por el éxito o
el fracaso sino por haber hecho el
esfuerzo por intentarlo y disfrutarlo
por reírte de ti mismo reírte en este
misterio que llamamos vida
por poner un pie delante del otro
y darte cuenta de que no es tan malo
entonces puedo dar otro paso
y continuar
y lentamente pero con seguridad te das
cuenta de que estás progresando
y mientras más avanzas más lo disfrutas
especialmente si no lo haces al último
minuto
voy a darte aproximadamente un minuto
para que repitas algo en tu mente que
espero que pueda desprogramar esos
pensamientos que han evitado que actúes
durante el siguiente minuto repite que
realmente disfrutas pasar a la acción
que tienes la fortuna de estar en una
posición que te permite actuar
el resultado será lo que sera
tú disfrutas pasar a la acción
tienes la fortuna de ser capaz de
hacerlo
y el resultado será algo que sera
continúa pensando esto durante el
siguiente minuto yo regreso no te
preocupes
muy bien
ahora cuando estés listo a tu tiempo
comienza a tomar conciencia de lo que te
rodea
hacer un poco más consciente de tu
cuerpo
de cada respiración
y lentamente
abre los ojos
para terminar te daré un último consejo
algunas veces pues ponemos alguna cosa
simplemente porque parece enorme o
abrumadora
algo que me gusta hacer en esos casos es
decir le voy a dedicar 20 minutos y veré
dónde me encuentro al final de ese lapso
si no hice ningún progreso no hay
problema solo fueron 20 minutos pero si
tuve algún avance perfecto le dedique 20
minutos y merezco un descanso
si después de descansar cinco o diez
minutos estoy listo para dedicarle otros
20 minutos maravilloso
si al final de esos 20 minutos quiero
continuar no debo detenerme debo seguir
cuando ves las cosas pensando que solo
le vas a dedicar 20 minutos dejan de
parecer tan intimidantes tú las
controlas dices puedo hacer cualquier
cosa durante 20 minutos y puedo
disfrutar de cualquier cosa durante 20
minutos
y vas a querer hacerlo
sonríe y pon manos a la obra y no solo
vas a avanzar sino que también la vas a
pasar bien
hazlo con una actitud alegre disfrútalo
sonríe y simplemente comienza
y creo que va a saber que procrastinar
has mucho menos